[Music]
Siri called June Mom this is FaceTime oh
gosh I need you to write a couple of
things down the car keys I just said
write it down you're not writing it down
Evan and I are headed to LAX and we need
you to pick us up on Monday keep your
location on the entire time I'm away no
fun got it
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
hi this is Grace Allen please leave a
message
Mom where are you guys
my mom never came home from her trip I
don't know where she is I'm calling
about a guest you had
um does anyone speak English
so is there anything I can do the best
thing you can do to help us is just wait
by your phone
I'm not giving up on my mom
and
he's held and ask for their security
footage
says she sees two American tourists at
the hardware store what did he buy just
this you think he did something to her
you're going through Kevin's email you
need to let the police handle this I
tried but we're running out of time who
are these people this woman calls him
Darren
hey we're gonna tell me my mom was
dating a felon you need to trust me
shocking your footage as leaked online
I have some questions regarding
something we're looking into has your
mom ever gone by any other names
what
the strangest case I've ever seen there
may be more than meets the eyes there
are some legit questions
it's actually a lot I want to talk with
you about
oh my God
[Music]
thank you